bonjour nous sommes jeudi 11 juin merci
de nous retrouver pour un nouveau numéro
de file echo votre magazine d'actualités
sur l'économie locale on commence tout
de suite avec les titres de cette
édition
dans l'actualité de cette semaine ce
jeudi la fédération nationale du
bâtiment a tenu son congrès annuel à
versailles l'occasion est l'occasion
également pour la chaude et vibrante de
ptc 50 ans et de tirer un bilan
cette année nous y étions nous
reviendrons également sur le trophée des
entreprises qui avaient le jeudi dernier
à la base de loisirs de 50 ans robin un
moyen de voir ses collègues de travail
différemment
enfin dans notre dossier de cette
semaine nous reviendrons sur
l'innovation en termes de recherche et
développement et de mobilité de nouveaux
projets étaient présentés cette semaine
lors des mots vod nous sommes allés à la
rencontre des entreprises yvelinoise et
cette semaine ce n'est pas un mais deux
entretiens que nous vous proposons d'en
philly qu à l'occasion de l'assemblée
générale du medef des yvelines nous
avons rencontré deux chefs d'entreprise
sébastien vers chris président et
fondateur du groupe avait now ainsi que
franck provost président et fondateur du
groupe provalliance ils ont accepté de
nous parler de leur parcours
d'entrepreneur mais avant d'écouter ces
témoignages je propose de passer en
revue l'actualité de la semaine
et je vous en parlais la semaine
dernière et le trophée le trophée des
entreprises s'est déroulée jeudi dernier
sur l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines
ce challenge a réuni 150 équipes
composées chacune de trois membres
au programme course vtt et canoë une
autre approche du travail une façon de
voir ses collègues différemment regardez
ce reportage signé mickaël miro et
elodie moines les sociétés étaient en
compétition sur l'île de loisirs de
saint quentin en yvelines la 8e édition
du trophée des entreprises a réuni 150
équipes pour poser chacune trois membres
des groupes étaient divisés en
catégories hommes femmes est mixte les
sociétés étaient en compétition sur
l'île de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines la 8e édition du trophée des
entreprises a réuni 150 équipes pour
poser chacune trois membres les propos
étaient divisés en catégories hommes
femmes est mixte au fil des allées pour
ce petit problème technique sachez que
la maison de l'emploi et des entreprises
de plaisir était en travaux depuis le
mois d'octobre dernier elle vient de
réouvrir ses portes dans des locaux
flambant neufs
elle propose trois services la mission
locale pour aider les jeunes de 16 à 25
ans à s'insérer professionnellement
l'antenne locale de pôle emploi qui a
doublé sa surface d'accueil le site
compte aussi le service développement
économique de la ville
un service d'autant plus important que
des projets sont en cours dans ce
domaine on écoute joséphine kossmann
berger maire de plaisir au micro de
catherine château le service de
développement économique c'est un
service qui travaille en lien avec les
entreprises et qui aujourd'hui est
plutôt dans une écoute renforcée puisque
nous souhaitons depuis pas mal de temps
je vais dire de bonne année en tout cas
avoir un contact beaucoup plus direct
avec les entreprises on a encore des
zones à développer sa des gâtines qui
mérite aussi un bon coup de
rafraîchissantes ni a aussi la zone de
ste apolline qui s'élancera en
développement plus tôt je dirais quand
on va rentrer au nez au sein de l'acas
qui à partir du 1er janvier
parlons bâtiment maintenant c'est la
première fois que se déroule cet
événement à versailles la fédération
nationale du bâtiment du bâtiment
organisée ce jeudi ainsi que demain son
congrès annuel dans la cité royale au
palais des congrès l'occasion de fêter
également le 50e anniversaire de la
fédération dans les yvelines et de
dresser un bilan du secteur du bâtiment
regarde
chefs d'entreprise artisans salariés
ils étaient près d'un millier à se
rendre à cet événement accueillir le
congrès annuel tout un symbole pour la
fédération du bâtiment des yvelines elle
fête cette année ses 50 ans une raison
de se réjouir malgré un contexte
économique plus que délicat ce qui nous
inquiète aujourd'hui c'est parmi nos
adhérents sur le premier trimestre 2015
nous avons soit plus de 60% des
entreprises qui n'ont qu'un carnet de
commandes de 2 mois nous nous constatons
que les dépôts de bilan sont de l'ordre
de 30 à 35 % pour des entreprises
bâtiments à versailles et alors qu'il y
à quelques temps sec ça visait des
entreprises jean djeunes récente qui
n'avait peut-être pas eu le temps de
s'installer au real man pour le
président de la fédération nationale le
bilan est contrasté
- 20 % de baisse d'activité depuis 2008
bien que l'exercice des promoteurs sont
le repartir à la hausse
s'il souhaite rassurer ses pairs l'objet
de ce congrès est aussi d'alerter les
pouvoirs publics et les élus locaux
le message principal est de leur dire
qu'il faut lancer les travaux maintenant
bien sûr on a conscience que la baisse
des dotations ne rend pas les choses
simples mais néanmoins il ya des
capacités de financement encore qui
existe est-ce qu'il faut pas regarder
comment optimiser le patrimoine qu'ils
ont peut-être en revendre certains qui
leur permettrait d'avoir un effet de
levier de financement pour en créer
d'autres de continuer aussi la
maintenance commencé à construire
maintenant mais également lutter contre
la fraude au détachement
telles sont les requêtes de la
fédération l'enjeu est important à
l'échelle nationale comme à l'échelle
locale
le bâtiment représente 10% de l'activité
économique dans les yvelines
enfin sachez que demain pierre cojan
succédera à daniel taravella le
président de la fédération française du
bâtiment des yvelines depuis six ans
enfin mercredi le medef des yvelines
s'est retrouvé à saint germain en laye
pour son assemblée générale l'occasion
pour bertrand de créer le président du
meet sd et vine d'afficher une
fédération unie et d'annoncer la mise en
place de nouvelles initiatives on écoute
tout de suite dont annoncé
aujourd'hui la naissance de travail fait
par la commission financement des
entreprises est un travail qui a été
très lourd qu'ils ont deux ans par des
entrepreneurs qui sont joints des
commissaires aux comptes dit la
comptable notre avec la banque de france
au travail et que les regards sont des
banques
et là on a un outil est là on va voir sa
première réalisation qui devra vraiment
une petite dead halak au financement de
l'entreprise
si vous l'avez compris on est pas on va
pas chercher des bdz de l'état on va se
trouver nous-mêmes les solutions pour
justement développé entreprises
développer l'emploi je propose
maintenant de passer à l'entretien la
semaine et cette semaine nous pouvons
vous proposons d'écouter deux
témoignages de chefs d'entreprise à
l'origine ils ont monté une tpe
aujourd'hui ils sont à la tête d'un
grand groupe
et pour eux tout a commencé dans les
yvelines ce sont sébastien envers chris
fondateur du groupe avait now ainsi que
franck provost fondateur et président du
groupe provalliance je vous propose tout
d'abord d'écouter sébastien vers chris
hill et yves binois est installé à
montigny-le-bretonneux
nous sommes ici avec sébastien
vercruysse président et fondateur du
groupe avait now située à montigny le
bretonneux
bonsoir vous êtes ici pour intervenir et
pour témoigner
l'entreprise de votre parcours c'est
bien ça c'est ça exactement à vénat
aujourd'hui c'est environ 170 personnes
25 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires nous avons neuf agences en
france donc notre siège social est basé
à saint quentin en yvelines dans le
domaine de l'intégration d'outils 3d et
de transformation numérique des
entreprises et donc nous nous lançons à
l'international a depuis quelques temps
voilà développement à l'international en
étant partie de la pépinière promo paul
à saint quentin en yvelines
alors expliquez moi voilà qu'est ce que
déjà l'histoire davet hanau est ce que
vous pouvez m'en dire un petit peu plus
sur votre parcours à vélo c'est un
groupe que j'ai créé avec mon frère en
2002 donc nous sommes partis de la
pépinière promo paul à
montigny-le-bretonneux notre notre
métier et notre entreprise travaille
autour des de l'intégration de logiciel
de 3d et de tout ce qui tourne autour de
ce qu'on appelle la transformation
numérique des entreprises et tout ça a
grandit petit à petit par non
aujourd'hui on travaille beaucoup
notamment par exemple sur l'impression
3d donc dans des domaines destinées aux
industriels
vous êtes si pour témoigner dans le
cadre une conférence de l'atp au groupe
international
quelle clé vous allez donner aux gens
qui sont présents ici pour vous écouter
pour apprendre votre expérience
les clés en tout cas qu'il nous nous ont
aidés à grandir c'est le fait de
considérer qu'une entreprise
premièrement notre métier c'est de
c'est de vendre on est on est tous des
commerçants conçoit un assureur un
banquier quelqu'un qui vend de
l'informatique comme moi on est déjà
avant tout des commerçants et donc qui
dit commerçant dit dit est très proche
très proche de ses clients
le deuxième point c'est l'innovation
c'est quelque chose qui concerne chaque
entreprise un boulanger peut innover un
assureur peut innover et l'innovation
c'est cette capacité que doit à mon avis
avoir un entrepreneur de se remettre en
question de remettre en question son
marché d'essayer de transgresser des
règles non pas des règles bien sûr légal
mais des règles d'habitude
et donc c'est surtout sur ceux sur ce
thème là que je vais essayer de de
transmettre mon expérience en france en
règle générale les entreprises sont bien
accompagnés à leur début au bout de
trois ans ça commence là être plus
compliqué puisque vous conseillerez aux
entrepreneurs qui veulent se lancer pour
éviter certains écueils réussir un
parcours comme le vôtre si quelqu'un
devait partir de zéro aujourd'hui je
conseillerais d'aller travailler dans un
domaine sur lequel il est passionné on a
la chance de travailler dans une
activité qui nous passionne et qui font
qu'aujourd'hui moi même et j'espère mes
collaborateurs et je pense que c'est le
cas
se lève le matin en étant content de
travailler dans le domaine dans lequel
et dans lequel il travaille en termes
vraiment d'étapes clés d'entrepreneuriat
il ya vraiment des étapes on va dire où
on ne peut pas à passer au dessus qui
sont très importantes pour justement un
pouvoir continuer parfois juste l'envié
ne suffit pas la principale chose que je
conseille à un entrepreneur c'est d'être
le premier vendeur de son entreprise est
un entrepreneur pour moi c'est pas un
comptable
il ya des experts comptables qui sont là
pour nous accompagner pour faire des
business plan etc
un entrepreneur n'est pas forcément le
meilleur technicien de son entreprise
parce qu'on peut embaucher des personnes
de la technique c'est pas non plus un
banquier c'est à dire qu'une entreprise
je vois beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise
qui met beaucoup d'argent et qui ont
vraiment du mal à vivre et donc un
entrepreneur son entreprise doit doit
elle même générer de l'argent avec sa
propre croissance
donc conseil numéro un
être auprès de ses clients pour proposer
son offre au quotidien l'important si
c'est peut-être de sa raccompagner c'est
très important dans les domaines sur
lesquels on n'est pas des spécialistes
et c'est mon cas je suis spécialiste de
pas grand chose au final
mais donc se faire accompagner par un
expert-comptable qui soit vraiment un
expert-comptable adapté à la taille de
son entreprise par des chambres de
commerce par le medef aussi qui moi m'a
beaucoup beaucoup aidé dans ma phase de
création mais le fait de rencontrer
beaucoup d'entrepreneurs des personnes
qui ont une une forte expérience c'est
quelque chose qui aide à réussir et qui
en tout cas permet d'éviter quelques
erreurs
selon vous quelles sont un peu les
freins aujourd'hui qui peut être on
pêche voilà l'entrepreneuriat d'évoluer
en france c'est l'administration la
lourdeur dans une entreprise et dans
certains domaines qui aujourd'hui sont
clé dans le développement de l'emploi en
france le domaine du numérique par
exemple nous sommes des entreprises sur
lequel on a besoin d'aller très vite
d'être très réactif d'être très agile et
l'administration les aides etc ne sont
souvent pas au rythme
que nous attendons nous en tant
qu'entrepreneur et du coup bah bien
souvent ces aides ont fait une croix
dessus parce que ça va pas assez vite
vous adhérez au medef des yvelines vous
avez justement voilà peut-être un regard
sur l'entrepreneuriat yvelinois est-ce
qu ici c'est peut-être plus facile de
monter son sa propre entreprise dans ce
département qui est très actif alors il
ya une vraie vivacité dans les yvelines
il ya des acteurs clefs il ya des zones
comme saint quentin en yvelines sur
laquelle nous sommes installés sur le
quai lien vraie dynamique avec des
universités avec des entreprises etc
donc il ya un terreau il faut savoir le
cultiver eh bien merci à sébastien la
crise pour ce témoignage
merci à vous et notre second témoignage
est celui de franck provost aujourd'hui
son groupe est numéro un européen et
numéro 2 mondial dans le secteur de la
coiffure ses 2400 salon installé dans 30
pays du monde accueille plus de 30
millions de clients par an et pour lui
tout a commencé dans les yvelines
regardez nous sommes baissiers avec
franck provost président et directeur de
groupe provalliance vous êtes ici pour
témoigner de votre parcours de chef
d'entreprise et car tout a commencé à
saint germain en laye dans les yvelines
avec votre premier salon je suis très
heureux d'être ici parce que ça a était
pile 40 ans que je joue verve ce premier
salon atteint germain en laye et donc
pour moi de revenir aujourd'hui c'est
super venir témoigner un petit peu du
parcours que finalement en démarrant
avec un premier salon à
saint-germain-en-laye on peut finalement
développé toute une entreprise qu est-ce
que les yvelines ce département un
caractère spécifique un bonne chance
mystique pour vous bien sûr surtout
saint germain en laye mais des yvelines
aussi puisque je vous verrai donc ce
premier salon à saint germain en laye et
ensuite les autres salons j'ai ouvert
dans les yvelines retourne
le saint germain en laye donc
effectivement c'est mon département
fétiche j'y ai habité longtemps
la région est superbe et puis je garde
beaucoup d'affection et d'attachement
parce que c'est grâce à ce premier salon
qui m'a permis d'en arriver là comme
j'aime dans une interview que ouvrir
votre deuxième salon avait été vraiment
compliqué passez-les pas venir avant un
entrepreneur donc c'est ondes c'est
vraiment ça une étape difficile pour
après pouvoir aller plus loin oui c'est
toujours le la deuxième affaire la plus
difficile quel que soit le métier d'air
parce que je pense que quand on
travaille dans monte la première affaire
ça fonctionne et tout est et après bonzi
la seconde ça va être la même chose
c'est pas forcément la même chose
d'une part et puis d'une autre paradis
on peut pas tous deux endroits donc
important d'avoir formé des équipes
auprès de soi qui ont la même culture
d'entreprise la même envie on doive
donner la même ambiance et donc il faut
se dédoubler donc ça c'est toujours très
compliqué parce que on peut pas souvent
c'est la première entreprise qui permet
la seconde
et si on laisse tomber la première avant
ta seconde marche et pas forcément
facile quoi savoir recruter justement
son tour et de ses collaborateurs
c'est aussi ça qui est important c'est
ça qui permet de voir plus loin et de
faire grandir son groupe son affaire je
dirais que c'est presque aussi important
de savoir s'entourer de collaborateurs
compétents non seulement nous dans notre
métier d des coiffeurs mais aussi après
quand on est une entreprise d'une
certaine taille il faut 6
va s'entourer au niveau comptable
directeurs financiers juristes et tous
effectivement ça passe par ça sinon ça
ne peut pas fonctionner quand c'est
clair mais je je je pense qu'il est
important
on a réussi par rapport à son métier et
donc il faut garder ce métier là et
savoir s'entourer de personnes qui
correspondent à ensuite toutes les
branches coin de ce qu on va nous
demander quelle période quelle étape
peut-être retiendrez-vous est elle
vraiment décisive dans votre parcours
quelque chose qu'il devait basculer qui
vous a justement permis d'accéder au
rang vous êtes actuellement c'est
relativement facile parce que j'ai
effectivement montré cette première
affaire avec des très bons
collaborateurs et ses collaborateurs
finalement je leur dois tout donc pour
pas les perdre moi j'ai ouvert des
nouveaux salons et qu'elle est associée
mais finalement c'est ce qui a permis
vraiment cette base de du groupe
donc effectivement c'est capital il faut
savoir les intéressés pour les conserver
tout simplement vous êtes a également
entourées de votre famille dans le
groupe pro vaillance c'est qui vous a
permis aussi c'est une des peut-être une
des étapes une des clés qui vous a
permis justement d'augmenter de pouvoir
aussi faire confiance plus facilement
alors aujourd'hui oui effectivement je
travaille avec famille enfin ma femme
s'est arrêtée de travailler mais j'ai ma
fille qui s'occupe de la communication
de tout groupe
de l'image et puis j'ai également
monfils qui a fait son parcours de
coiffeur et qui travaillent tous les
deux au stration voilà et ça permet
surtout de capitaliser sur l'avenir donc
c'est une confiance aussi pour les
franchisés qui viennent nous rejoindre
et puis ça permet donc une pérennité je
rassure tout le monde avec votre analyse
de chefs d'entreprise et votre
expérience à si vous pensez que
actuellement ce serait possible pour eux
j'espère coiffeur ou d'un autre ou
d'artisans notre métier de se lancer et
de pouvoir dans voilà ce contexte
économique assez compliqué d'arriver à
monter un grand groupe et de pouvoir se
développer il ya peut-être trop de
freins actuellement je crois
qu'aujourd'hui tout est encore possible
moi quand j'ai commencé ses parents que
j'entendais peut-être trop tard le voilà
et ainsi de suite
je crois que j'ai jamais trop tard donc
ce qui est important c'est de d'avoir
cette passion peut-être pas d'avoir une
ambition non plus au départ de dire
super fr je montais premier salon par
exemple
moi j'ai jamais réagi comme ça c'est
fait
étape par étape s'il ya des jeunes qui
m'écoutent je les encourage à choisir
des métiers où justement on peut on peut
se développer de cette façon et est
monté des affaires quoi et je crois que
c'est vraiment possible
il ya pas une peur qui s'installe quand
on se lance au niveau international
comme vous l'avez fait
alors oui bonne c'est toujours c'est
toujours une sur une appréhension est ce
que c'est vraiment c'est toujours une
idée des certaines choses comme on monte
la première à faire aussi mais voilà là
ça va être compliqué la comptabilité la
gestion le personnel machin et pour
l'international et bien c'est la même
chose quoi finalement dans notre métier
du moins bon je connais pas tous des
professions qui sont présentes ce soir
c'est vrai que les français ont souvent
du mal à s'exporter
mais aujourd'hui je pense que ça a
changé de plus en plus
actuellement les jeunes partent à
l'étranger et décide de faire une
carrière beaucoup plus qu'auparavant
avant il y avait beaucoup ne sont pas
les italiens voyageaient beaucoup plus
que les français
aujourd'hui je crois que tu as a changé
si vous aviez trois conseils à donner un
jeune entrepreneur et chinois par
exemple qui veut se lancer qu'elle
s'arrête là bas je dirais trois mots
quoi la passion la passion et la passion
je crois que c'est ça qui doit nous
animer et si on aime ce qu'on fait c'est
facile
moi personnellement j'ai jamais eu
vraiment l'impression de travailler
pourquoi parce que c'est toujours été
passionné et finalement ça m'a toujours
amusé quand il ya des nouvelles
perspectives encore à accomplir pour moi
oui bien sûr il faut il faut continuer à
avoir des objectifs c'est indispensable
une
une entreprise qui n'a plus d'objectif
bah c'est une entreprise qui va
automatiquement regret c est donc nous
aujourd'hui évidemment on vise beaucoup
sur l'international et on a
effectivement quelques cibles en vue
on continue que très bien et bien merci
introuvable avoir répondu à nos
questions merci et passons maintenant
aux chiffres de la semaine c'est tout de
suite
15,5 pour sont celles au taux de
création d'entreprises pour les yvelines
en 2014
le territoire fait partie des dix
meilleurs département en terme de
création d'entreprise à savoir que 58,4
pour cent de ses créations sont des auto
entreprises plus de 500 mille
entreprises ont été créées en france en
je vous propose maintenant de parler
mobilité transports et innovation avec
les dossiers de la semaine la recherche
et le développement au service de la
mobilité de demain c'est un peu tout
l'enjeu du cluster d'entreprises movéo
il rassemble sur le secteur de la
mobilité des transports de la recherche
et du développement des pme des
laboratoires des grands groupes ainsi
que des instituts de recherche français
mais aussi yvelinois nous sommes allés
cette semaine au forum
armand peugeot à poissy à l'occasion des
mauvais au dé découvrir les innovations
en matière de mobilité et réalisé par
les acteurs du département des yvelines
un dossier réalisé avec william el est
romand respini pour le montage la
voiture de demain et ses composants se
trouve peut-être ici près de 400
participants se sont donné rendez-vous à
poissy pour découvrir les innovations en
matière de mobilité intelligente et
propre par milieu plusieurs entreprises
installées dans les yvelines comme ep
tender basée à poissy la société vient
de développer un module d'énergie
remarquable pour recharger les voitures
électriques pas développer cette petite
remorque on attelle à la voiture
uniquement quelques jours dans l'année
on le loue en mode auto partage et donc
on ne payera pour ce prolongateur
d'autonomie que en proportion usages
qu'on en a et donc à l'intérieur on
trouve un moteur de voiture
et une génératrice donc vous avez ici le
moteur de voiture évidemment ça une
petite voiture il se trouve que c'est un
moteur de thatta c'est un bicylindre un
projet à plus d'un million d'euros qui a
pu se concrétiser et gagner en
visibilité grâce à nouvelle
l'existence de ce type de forums et de
kloster est très important et puis
mauvais ou nous a aidés également sous
l'angle de la labellisation de notre
projet pour aider à accéder à des
financements
nous voulons montrer que les pôles de
compétitivité ça fonctionne et que l'on
passe vraiment du projet de r&d
pur produit
sur le marché et donc ses lacs ce qu'on
a voulu donner aujourd'hui à cette
journée en montrant les produits issus
des projets de r&d initié grâce à
mauvais au lait grâce à l'interaction
l'écosystème d'innovation animé par
locaux aujourd'hui 24 projets sont mises
à l'honneur des serveurs des
applications la technologie digitale est
de plus en plus présente sur le secteur
de la mobilité la plateforme pro civique
un logiciel destiné aux industriels et
élaboré par une entreprise versaillaise
en est l'exemple c'est une solution
qu'on propose à l'industrie pour les
aider à mettre au point à valider et à
identifier les cas limites les
conditions limites de leurs systèmes
d'aidé à la conduite
donc tout ça au service évidemment de
pouvoir ajouter des fonctions
d'intelligence à bord de véhicules les
systèmes d'aidé à la conduite sont en
plein essor ils sont à présent
considérés comme des réponses aux
problèmes de consommation énergétique
quelques années en arrière on voyait des
fonctions à paraître sur le
certains véhicules haut de gamme
maintenant enfin le
la tendance chez les constructeurs
français comme comme à l'international
si aussi de savoir amener ses fonctions
de confort et puis d'aller vers des
fonctions liées à la sécurité du
véhicule et du conducteur
d'amener ces éléments là vers les gammes
grand public
donc aujourd'hui on a vraiment un marché
qui est
en train de devenir de plus en plus
important du côté des véhicules
électriques la société muses située à
conflans sainte honorine et créé en 2009
a vu son projet le move il se
concrétiser grâce à movéo une quinzaine
de véhicules de livraison adaptable ont
déjà été vendus la société a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires de plus de 320 milles
euros en plus de deux ans une situation
qui devrait évoluer positivement selon
le président de la société toutes les
villes et rafraîchissent à la livraison
propres et donc aujourd'hui c'est cette
c'est ce pas là de la réglementation de
la livraison propre qui est en train
d'être fait et qui fera en sorte que le
marché décolle véritablement mais
attention on entendit un marché
décollera c'est pas des milliers de
véhicules
c'est des centaines de véhicules même si
une centaine de move il vendu suffirait
à assurer la pérennité de cette société
de 22 salariés
il existe certes un frein au
développement de ces secteurs des
problématiques que tente de résoudre des
instituts et organismes de recherche
comme vd comme intégré au cluster les
réglementations doivent évoluer
donc ça prendra nécessairement un peu
plus de temps mais il y aura des
expérimentations
des journées comme mauvais audet s'est
également de rencontrer les pouvoirs
publics qui sont présents j'en ai vu
plusieurs aujourd'hui pour faire tout le
lobbying nécessaire à l'évolution de ces
réglementations près de 40 entreprises
yvelinoise sont membres du pôle de
compétitivité mov'éo a déjà accompagné
tour à 175 projets de recherche et
développement pour un montant de 1
milliard quatre cent cinquante millions
d'euros depuis sa création
et pour information c'est l'entreprise
muse et son mauvais pied reçu un mauvais
award dans la catégorie mobilité
propreté et économe c'est bientôt la fin
notre mission mais avant de nous quitter
je propose de regarder ensemble agenda
la semaine de rendez vous cette semaine
à ne pas manquer bg yvelines organise un
événement la première table ouverte aux
envie d'entreprendre
à cette occasion vous pourrez assister à
des démonstrations des différents outils
et actions que bg e développe pour
accompagner les créateurs d'entreprise
le rendez vous a lieu ce jeudi 11 juin à
partir de 18h iphone enfin mardi 16 juin
à 16 heures c'est le lancement du
nouveau réseau plateau organisé par la
chambre de commerce et d'industrie de
versailles yvelines
au programme des thématiques liées à la
jeune entreprise que les membres définir
eux-mêmes selon leurs besoins
n'hésitez pas à vous renseigner auprès
de la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
des yvelines si vous êtes intéressé
c'est la fin de notre émission je vous
remercie de nous avoir suivis je vous
donne rendez vous la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de file echo je
vous souhaite une très bonne soirée